COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERING SENATE
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC. CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING AND THE
CAPITAL WITH NONE OF OUR
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
AND TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TO. THE PROCESS I'M SORRY THE
NUMBER TO CALL. TODAY TO
PARTICIPATE IS. 844-291-6364
ONCE AGAIN EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT SIX
ONE ZERO ONE EIGHT FIVE ONCE
AGAIN. EIGHT SIX ONE. ZERO ONE
EIGHT FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO ACCESS
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM FIFTY
THE SENATE OR AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME
AND I WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE SUCH A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE
IT AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY. AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING. AS
THIS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE. OR HALF THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT A HEARING AS CLOSE
TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR.
JOINING US ONLINE. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON
THE AGENDA HOWEVER WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS ONE ITEM. EIGHT BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE
REMEMBER TO HAVE YOUR MIKE ON
SPEAKING THE MICROPHONE RUBIO.
RUBIO PRESENT JONES HERE JONES
PRESENT ARCHULETA. BATES HERE
BATES PRESENT BORDERS FURTHER
OR JUST PRESENT BOB. ISN'T DOT
PRESENT GLAZER PRESENT GLAZER
PRESENT MYSELF. HER TARA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN IS PRESENT
PORTANTINO AIR PORTANTINO
PRESENT ROCK HERE ROCK RATHER
WELL FOR. THE CONSULTANT ALSO
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE ITEM SB
SEVEN THIRTEEN RUBIO DO I HAVE
A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SO MOVED BY SENATOR
DODD. CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RUBIO HI RUBIO I JONES I DON'T
BUY OR TO LET. BATES HI BATES
HI BORDERS FIVE BORDERS BY GOD
HI DON I GLAZER AYE. GLAZER AYE
HUESO. OUR DAUGHTER MELENDEZ I
WENT AS I PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH FIVE. HI.
THE BILL HAS A NUMBER TO PUT ON
A CALL. THANK YOU FOR THAT AT
TODAY WE WILL BEGIN WITH SB SIX
FIFTY FIVE. WELCOME SENATOR
PROPERTY MAY PRESENT BILL SB
SIX FIFTY FIVE WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THE GROOM JUROR AND- SB
SIX. SIXTY FIVE BUILT ON SOME
WORK TO OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. A RICARDO LARA
WHEN I WORKED ON IN CREATING A
INSURANCE OVERSEE. SURVEY ON SP
FIVE THREE FOUR. THE GOAL WAS
REALLY SIMPLY TO FIX THE GAP IN
INFORMATION LOCKED UP THIS
SURVEY SUNSET AND TO COLLECT
DATA IN ORDER TO FIND THE BEST
APPROACH IS TO EVALUATE
INCREASE DIVERSITY IN INSURANCE
MARKETS- THIS BILL JUST EXPANDS
UPON THAT OF THE WORK THAT WE
DID ON IT. SB FIVE THREE FOUR
WILL HELP STRENGTHEN EQUITY
DIVERSITY TRANSPARENCY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE OTHER THREE
COMPONENTS IS MEASURE. IT
LOWERS THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
PREMIUM REPORTING THRESHOLD
FROM A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
AS A RELATION INSURANCE COMPANY
GOVERNING BOARD AND SUPPLIER
DIVERSITY DATA- THIS IS- THE
STARZ SHOW HELPS CAPTURE A
BIGGER SNAPSHOT. OF INSURANCE
INDUSTRIES DIVERSE SPENDING AND
BOARD OF RIDE A VARIETY AS A
WHOLE. BY THE GOVERNING BOARD
SURVEY REMAINS AS IT WAS HIS
STROLLER VOLUNTARILY A
VOLUNTARY OUR PROCESS GIVING
EACH BOARD MEMBER THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SELF REPORT.
THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
CONFIDENTIAL- THE SECOND PIECE
TO SIMPLY CODIFIES REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS ON
INSURANCE COMPANIES GOVERNING
BOARDS TO INCLUDE. ARE
REQUIRING INSURANCE COMPANIES
TO PROVIDE A GOVERNING BOARD
DIVERSITY POLICY STATEMENT OR
MEASURABLE GOALS. AND FROM THE
DATA COLLECTED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN A WE FOUND AMONG
THE THIRTEEN HUNDRED BOARD
SEATS SURVEY. 80% WERE OCCUPIED
BY FOR CATIONS AND 70% OF THEM
ARE DEFINED AS MALE. IN ORDER
TO HELP MANAGE SURE IT'S
INDUSTRY PROPERLY REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STATE. THIS
MEASURE SIMPLY ASKS INSURANCE
URINE FOR ME INSURERS TO
RESPOND TO THE SURVEY. THEY
INCLUDE A MEASURE REAL
STATEMENT ON THEIR GOALS FOR
INCREASING. INCLUSIVITY AND
FINALLY SB SIX FIVE DEFINES THE
TERMS DIVERSE INVESTMENT
MANAGERS IN THE C<c.cyan>G</c>
PROGRAMMING POINT SIMPLY STANDS
FOR CALIFORNIA ORGANIZED
INVESTMENT NETWORK IT SERVES AS
A NATIONAL MODEL TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP IN INCREASING
INSURANCE INDUSTRY INVESTMENTS
AND UNDERSERVED RURAL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. SB SIX FIVE FIVE
BILLS UPON THIS SUCCESS. RAGU
SUCCESSFUL DATA THAT WAS
PULLED. FROM INSURERS AND USERS
AND- AND IMPLEMENTATION MEASURE
MEASURABLE GOALS FOR DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION VESSEL PRACTICES.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE AND ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK WITH US TO
BRING US TO THIS POINT TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS MEASURE AS IT
MOVES TO JUDICIARY FORGETS
OFFICE COMMITTEE TODAY AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER CARLOTTA WE HAVE
MICHAEL MARTINEZ WHOSE
DISCIPLINE SENIOR DEPUTY- TO
THE- COMMERCIAL ALARM IN THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. AND ACTOR
PREDOMINANCE RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD BEFORE WE MOVE
FORWARD I DO NEED TO ADVISE
THAT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS. AND CLEANING
TOOL A PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE
CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY EACH SITE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME NOT TO EXCEED THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. WE WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH MISTER MARTINEZ YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR RUBIO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF
OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA. AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. WE ARE PROUD SPONSOR
OF. SB SIX FIVE FIVE AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BRADFORD
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THIS
BILL DOES BUILD UPON THE
SUCCESS OF OUR PREVIOUSLY
SPONSORED BILL LAST SESSION SB
FIVE THIRTY FOUR- IN WHICH WE
PARTNERED WITH. AUTHOR SENATOR
BRADFORD. WILL BUILD ON THE
PROGRESS OF OUR NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED INSURANCE DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE. PLEASE KNOW THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
MEASURE. AND HAVE APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATIONS TO DATE.
UNDER THE NEAR TO SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS REPORTING
THRESHOLD IN THE BILL THERE
WOULD BE A MODEST INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF COMPANIES
REQUIRED TO REPORT. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ASSISTING THE
SMALLER COMPANIES TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE ADEQUATE TIME
AND RESOURCES TO PREPARE WHICH
INCLUDES PROVIDING
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING SESSIONS
BY DEPARTMENT STAFF. THERE'S
ALSO IN ADDITION TO THE TO OUR
COMMITMENT THERE'S ALSO A
THIRTY DAY EXTENSION. THAT IS
ALREADY PERMITTED BY CURRENT
LAUDED FOR THOSE COMPANIES THAT
MAY NEED SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
OUR SYSTEM TO COMPLETE THE
SURVEY. HOW I DID WANT TO NOTE
THAT MANY INSURANCE COMPANIES
CURRENTLY SHARE THE GOVERNING
BOARD GOALS AND POLICY
STATEMENTS WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
TODAY. AND WE ARE SEEKING TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND ASSIST BOTH
COMPANIES THAT THAT HAVE NOT
PROVIDED GOALS OR STATEMENT IN
THE PAST. BUT THERE'S ALSO
PUBLICLY HELD COMPANIES FOR
DIVERSITY POLICY GOLDEN
STATEMENT READILY AVAILABLE TO
SHAREHOLDERS TODAY. ART OF THE
COMPANY'S PROXY STATEMENT. AND
THEN WE ALSO DO BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL PROPOSED LANGUAGE
PROVIDES COMPANIES WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY REGARDING WHAT IT
DIVERSITY POLICY STATEMENT
ENTAILS. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
LANGUAGE. SHOULD BE TAKEN AS AS
NO MEANS TO BE AN EXHAUSTIVE
LIST. WE YOU WANT TO AUTHORS
THAT THE BOARD DIVERSITY SURVEY
AND RELATED DATA INCLUDING THE
POLICY GOALS AND STATEMENTS.
ARE TO BE REPORTED TO THE
DEPARTMENT CONFIDENTIALLY AND
THEN PUBLISHED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE AGGREGATE SO
AS NOT TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
ANY COMPANY OR BOARD MEMBER.
COMMISSIONER A LOT IN THE
DEPARTMENT MATCHING UNWAVERING
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY EQUITY
AND INCLUSION. AND BELIEVE THE
COMMUNITIES WE SERVE EXPECT US
TO USE EVERY POSSIBLE TOOL-
THAT WE HAVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF THE COMEDIANS AFTER
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL AND WE
LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
COOPERATION AS THIS BILL MOVES
FOR THE PROCESS. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR ITEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTINEZ AND
NOW WE WILL MOVE ON. TO OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. ODD LET
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
GALLERY. ANYONE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT. SEEN NONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. SEEN
NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
THE OTHER TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIFTY FIVE. WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE IN ZERO JUST BE ONE
MOMENT. THANK YOU. UHHUH. HOW
MY COMES FROM LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARK MINE I VOTE IN THE
COURT SB SIX FIFTY FIVE AS A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT WHO WON
FIFTY INSURANCE COMPANIES AS
DIVERSE AS A BEAUTIFUL STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONE MORE TIME TO ENSURE WE'VE
HEARD FROM EVERY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY FROM THE OPPOSITION. SO WE
WILL MOVE OVER TO THE GALLERY
TO SEE THERE'S ANYONE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION. SEEN NONE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. HAVE YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE POP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION AT SB
SIX FIFTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION- ESPYS
SIX FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANK YOU TO ALL THE
SUPPORTERS I CALLED IN AND
OPPOSITION WE WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS DID ANY OF THAT MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. BY
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRWMAN- AND I'M HAPPY IT
IS- SUPPORT THE BILL AND MOVE
MAKE THE MOTION FOR APPROVAL
ONE OF THE TIMES REYES HAD A
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR
OR MISTER MARTINEZ- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS ARE GOING WELL
WITH THE- WITH THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES BUT THERE ARE FEW.
DETAILS THAT STILL NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT AND JUST. WANTED TO
CONFIRM THAT THE AUTHOR AND-
THE DEPRIVE INSURANCE OFFICES
ARE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND WORKING
OUT THOSE DETAILS. ARE YOU WANT
ME TO RESPOND. WHAT DO WE HAVE
MISTER MARTINEZ ALWAYS WANTED
WE ARE RESPOND YES WITHOUT A
DOUBT WE'RE COMMITTED. THE
WORKING ALL STAKEHOLDERS BOTH
IN SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION OF
THIS BILL AS STATED IF IT MOVES
FORWARD WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DIALOGUE AS WE HAVE- THIS IS
NOT A NEW ISSUE AGAIN THIS IS
EXTENSION OF WHAT WE DID. A
YEAR AGO AND- SP FIVE THREE
FOUR SHOW- WE KNOW IT'S A LOT
OF INTERESTED PARTIES TO WE'RE
COMMITTED- BOTH MYSELF AS
AUTHOR AND INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER AND HIS STAFF AS
WELL SO. YES THANK YOU NOT
SURPRISED BY THE ANSWER AND I'M
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
OF THANK YOU MANAGER THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE WE
OFTEN STATE OUR STRENGTH IS IN
OUR DIVERSITY AND IT SHOULD BE
REFLECTED IN OUR INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AS IT HAS BEEN- IN
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING ELSE-
THAT WE DO. IN OUR DAILY LIFE-
BUSINESSES ARE. MADE BETTER-
NOT ONLY BY HAVING A DIVERSE
CLIENT BASE BUT A- DIVERSE WORK
FORCE AS WELL. AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS TRULY
MODEL WHAT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
FOR THE LAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
WHICH WAS IMPLEMENTED IN THERE
AND- UTILITY SPACE BY THE LATE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN GOING MORE WHEN
SHE AUTHORED WHAT'S NOW. KNOWN
AS JUNIOR ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX
WHICH ENCOURAGED. CONTRACTING
AND PROCUREMENT AND HAVING
DIVERSITY- IN THE UTILITY
INDUSTRY AND THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO BUILD UPON. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY- NOT ONLY
CONTRACT TO PROCURE BUT THEIR
BOARDS ALSO ARE REFLECTIVE. OF
THE GREAT DIVERSITY CALIFORNIAN.
I SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR THE BILL HAS
BEEN BY SEN JOHN. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST. RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS REMEMBER TO KEEP YOUR
MICROPHONE ON. RUBIO HI. BILL
JONES I DON'T I ARCHULETA.
BATES HI BATES BY BORDERS BY
BORDERS I DON AND I. THOUGHT I
GLAZER AYE. GLAZER AYE HUESO
HI. WITH A HIGH REGARD. MELINDA
PORTANTINO HI UNTIL I ROTH HI.
ROTH HI. BILL IS NINE VOTES BUT
ON A CALL. THANK YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD WE MUST ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES YOU SHOULD HAVE
ALL RECEIVED A COPY WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE COMMITTEE RULES
ARE ADOPTED THANK YOU. WE WILL
NOW MOVE ONTO OUR NEXT AUTHOR.
WELCOME SENATOR ALSO YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB THREE
THIRTY FOUR WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- YES I'M
HERE TO PRESENT- SB THREE THREE
FOUR WELL THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE PRIVATE FOR PROFIT
PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ONE. A YEAR TO
ALL APPROPRIATE STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH SAFETY FIRE AND JAIL
STANDARDS TO MEET AND MAINTAIN
SPECIFIC INSURANCE COVERAGES.
THREE SUBMIT COMPLETE QUARTERLY
COMPLIANCE REPORTS OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS THE BOTH INSURANCE
PROVIDER COMPANY AND THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
AND LAST INSURANCE COMPANIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE. FOR ENSURING
COMPLIANCE AND WOULD TERMINATE
OF FACILITIES INSURANCE
COVERAGE IF THESE REQUIREMENTS
ARE NOT MET- SEVERAL PRIVATE
PROFIT FOR PROFIT DETENTION
FACILITIES HAVE A HISTORY OF
VERY POOR CONDITIONS. IN
RESPONSE CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN A
DEFINITIVE STANCE TO IMPROVE
THE CONDITIONS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AB THIRTY TO PROHIBIT
THE OPERATION OF A FOR PROFIT
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITY OR
PRISON. AFTER JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY UNFORTUNATELY-
UNDER THE PREVIOUS IT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION THE- COMPANIES
RUSH TO ENTER INTO A SERIES OF
CONTRACTS IN AN APPARENT.
ATTEMPT TO CIRCUMVENT AB THIRTY
TWO MEANWHILE MEN AND WOMEN ARE
STILL DETAINED IN TERRIBLE
CONDITIONS THERE ARE NUMEROUS
REPORTS DETAILING THOSE
CONDITIONS AND ABUSIVE
TREATMENT OF PEOPLE INCLUDING
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN US
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
REPORT. FINDING THAT THE
ADELANTO DETENTION FACILITY
FAILED TO MEET MANY OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S OWN STANDARDS AND
OPERATORS DID NOT ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS DESPITE REPEATED
WARNINGS IT WAS ANOTHER REPORT
IN USA TODAY OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS
ANOTHER AND THEN ANOTHER USC
STUDY. THE SAFETY AND WELFARE
OF THOSE DETAINED IN FOR PROFIT
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL DETENTION
FACILITIES IS THREATENED EVEN
MORE UNDER COVERT- DO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC- THERE
WERE REPORTS OF A LACK OF
ACCESS TO SOAP SANITIZER. OTHER
PERFECT- PERSONAL PROTECTION
EQUIPMENT AND NOT ALLOCATED
SPACE FOR SOCIAL DISTANCING
THAT INCLUDES AN ACCOUNT OF
SEVENTY DETAINEES SHARING FIVE
BARS OF SOAP. AND GUARDS COMING
IN AND OUT OF DORMS WITHOUT
PERSONAL PROTECTION EQUIPMENT-
IN LAST YEAR THE SAN DIEGO
BASED O. TIENEN MESSA DETENTION
FACILITY REPORTED NOT BREAK A
HUNDRED ELEVEN PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY. AND TWENTY FIVE
STAFFERS AND THE FIRST SCOLDED-
NINETEEN DEATH OF A DETAINEE-
COLLEAGUES THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL APPLY EQUALLY TO FOR
PROFIT FACILITIES ENGAGE IN
CIVIL DETENTION AND CRIMINAL
DETENTION. WELL WITH ME I HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE COAST
SPONSORS- MICHAEL MARTINEZ
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. LOT UP AND DOES A
BILL BILL GALLO DIRECTOR POLICY
FOR- CHIRLA TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND THE MICHAEL OF MISTER
MARTINEZ CAN ALSO HELP. WITH
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THIRTY FOUR
WE WILL BEGIN WITH- MISTER
MARTINEZ FROM CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE YOU MAY
BEGIN. THANK YOU CHAIR RUBIO BY
CHER JOHNSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL MARTINEZ HERE
ON BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. SURE SURE LOT IS
VERY PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE WITH THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR TO
OF THE TAHOE FOR HER TREMENDOUS
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING THIS
MEASURE. WE AGREE WITH ALL OF
THE EXPERTS SENATORS REMARKS
JUST STATED ON THIS MEASURE.
AND JUST KNOW THAT SEVERAL OF
THESE FOR PROFIT PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTERS
CONTINUED OPERATING THE STATE'S
TODAY AND THEY HAVE
CONSISTENTLY. FAILED TO MEET
MINIMUM LOCAL STATE. AND
FEDERAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
CONSEQUENCES TODAY. IF THEY DO
NOT MEET THESE BASIC STANDARDS.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THESE
PRIVATE FACILITIES TO ADHERE TO
THE SAME. HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS CURRENTLY FOLLOWED BY
CALIFORNIA'S OWN STATE AND
LOCAL PUBLICLY MANAGED
FACILITIES THEREBY REDUCING
RISKS AND AVOIDING POTENTIAL
LOSSES FOR INSURANCE COMPANIES
WE BELIEVE SENATE BILL THREE
THREE FOUR. SHOULD PROVIDE A
POWERFUL MOTIVATION FOR PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT PRISONS AND
DETENTION FACILITIES THROUGH
HERE SO LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
STANDARDS WHILE ALSO ENSURING
THAT THESE FACILITIES. MAINTAIN
COMPREHENSIVE INSURANCE
COVERAGE BUILDING ON THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE'S
REPEATED EFFORTS TO REGULATE
AND RESTRICT THE USE OF PRIVATE
PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES IN THE STATE. AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY ENSURE THAT
BASIC HEALTH SAFETY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ARE AFFORDED TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS DETAINED
IN OUR STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVER THANK YOU. THE
YOU MISTER MARTINEZ WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO JOSEPH THE YELLOW
FROM COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS LOS ANGELES
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU- JUST
OF THE DELEGATE RICHARD LAPSED
AND WE- THREE SHARED- THAT ARE
GOOD AT SOME ORANGE JUICE IN
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT PRIVATE
ATTENTION ACCOUNTABILITY ACT I
MENTIONED WILL PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR PROFIT
DETENTION FACILITIES AND
PRISONS OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA
TO MEET AND MAINTAIN INSURANCE
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDING WORKERS
COMPENSATION AND LIABILITY AND
HER TO ALL THE STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH. AND SAFETY I SANDERS.
WE BELIEVE THAT YOUR LAP. THAT
THESE BILLS IT'S CRITICAL TO
THE HUMAN AND SHE WAS. OF
IMMIGRANTS ARE A- PEOPLE THAT
CENTER. AS MENTION WE HAVE A-
NUMBER OF THAT WHEN DID THE
PENSIONS AND AS WOULD
CREDIBILITY I THINK COMPANIES.
WHAT PROPERTY FROM THE DEPEND
OF INDIVIDUALS- WITH A MORE WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE'S STILL
WRITTEN ONLINE TO WHAT THE
STATE. ASSAULTED AND THAT IS TO
PUT. A SINGLE- RIGHT OPEN BY
ENACTING PUBLIC INSPECTION
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF UP FATHERS
LIKE TO DO AND CENTERS. WHICH
IS ANOTHER STEP ALL. AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY- THE AND I.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
YELLOW WE WANT MOVE ON TO
WITNESS AND SUB HERE AND THE
GAL. SEEN WE WILL MOVE TO IT IN
ROOM TWELVE AND SAID OF SB
THREE THIRTY FOUR. CNN WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITH WE TO TEST VIA
THE CALL FOR A TELECONFERENCE
SERVE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THIRTY FOUR WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE TWO IN Q. ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION WITH A
LONG HISTORY OF OPPOSING
PRIVATE PRISONS AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT- THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES INTO IT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION WE WILL FIRST
MOVED TO THE WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. C. NINE WE WILL
MOVE TO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. HAVING NONE WE WILL NOW
MOVE OVER TO WITNESSES READY TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
OR THIS MODERATOR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WE
NEED TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE THIRTY FOUR. WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FOUR
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT SINCE YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU MODERATOR-
THANK YOU TO ALL THAT CALLED IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WE WILL%
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS TWENTY MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY THEME NONE. OF SENATOR
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DO I HAVE A MOTION MOVED
BY SENATOR DOT. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON THE
JUDICIARY RUBIO HI RUBIO I
JONES NO JON SNOW ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I BATES. OKAY THE NOT
VOTING BORDERS. DOT BY DOT HI
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE HUESO BY
MYSELF I HER DAUGHTER I RETIRE
HI MELENDEZ PORTANTINO HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI. ROTH HI.
THE BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES FOR
ONE AGAINST. THANK YOU SENATOR
DROPS ON. WE WILL NOW LEFT A
CALL ON BILLS- CONSULTANT
PLEASE PUT THE CALL OUT WE WILL
START WITH SB SIX FIFTY FIVE I
SENATOR BRADFORD. SB SIX FIFTY
FIVE EARLIER NINE VOTES ARE YOU
LETTER. FRAUDULENT I HER TADO I
FOR TOTAL. MELINDA'S THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN BOTH OUT. WE NOW
MOVE ON TO CAN CALENDAR. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CONSENT- S. P.
SEVEN ONE THREE HAS NINE VOTES
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA HI HUESO I
RESERVED HI RETARDED I RETIRED.
FLOORS FOR VOTES FOR THE BILL
IS OUT. THANK YOU TO EVERY FOR
PATIENCE CLUB AND ALL THOSE
THAT CALLED OUT THE AGENDA IS
NOW CONCLUDED THAT COMMITTEE ON
INSURANCE IS A JOHN THANK YOU
EVERYONE.